They say that the first impression
is the last impression — but what
if everything after that first
impression sucks? These infamous
flicks piqued viewers' interests… only
to drop the ball mere moments later.
The third "Austin Powers" installment starts off
with such a bang that it's a shame the rest of the
movie can't live up to it. The opening set piece
is an over-the-top action parody of Austin himself
with none other than Tom Cruise donning the
shag-a-licious secret agent's thick glasses and
'60s threads. Kevin Spacey shows up as Dr. Evil,
Danny DeVito plays Mini-Me, and Gwyneth Paltrow
stars as Austin's love interest. It is revealed to
be directed by none other than Steven Spielberg,
who responds to Austin's criticisms of the
sequence by holding up one of his three
Oscars. It all ends with an elaborate dance
number over the opening credits, featuring
further cameos by Quincy Jones and Britney Spears
as a fembot. It's a testament to the franchise's
popularity at the time that so many A-listers
volunteered their talents for just a few minutes.
"Very shagadelic, baby! Yeah!”
A weird amalgamation of "Goldfinger" and
"Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade,"
the film finds Austin Powers traveling back
in time to rescue his kidnapped father,
British secret agent Nigel Powers,
from Dr. Evil. When he lands in 1975,
Powers teams up with American agent Foxxy
Cleopatra — played by none other than
Beyonce — to keep Dr. Evil from taking over the
world with Goldmember, a Dutch supervillain with
peeling skin and golden genitals. Although
the movie has its fair share of laughs,
the spark from the first two is missing,
and the critical reaction reflects that.
The success of "Who Framed Roger
Rabbit" inspired animation legend
Ralph Bakshi to try his hand at a
version for adults. Unfortunately,
the man who made cartoons X-rated with "Fritz the
Cat" had lost some of his edge by the time "Cool
World" came around. He seemed to have lost
some of his skills as a filmmaker as well,
since the live-action and animated elements
rarely seem to be existing within the same frame.
The film begins in 1940s Las Vegas, where WWII
vet Frank Harris is somehow teleported into the
animated universe of Cool World, eventually
becoming a police detective. Flash forward to
1992, when animator Jack Deebs is released from
a 10-year prison sentence. While behind bars,
he created the successful comic strip "Cool
World," based on weird dreams he'd been
having. Jack is sucked into the animated realm,
where he's seduced by his cartoon creation,
Holli Would. Holli wants to become
a real woman by sleeping with Jack,
even though sex between "doodles"
and "noids" is strictly forbidden.
Although "Cool World" has developed
a bit of a cult following,
it was universally panned by critics when
it was first released. Few people found
much of anything to like about it,
especially when held up against the
near-seamless integration of animation and
live-action in "Who Framed Roger Rabbit."
Say what you will about "Fast & Furious"
— the critically maligned fourth entry in
the long-running franchise — but it features
a banger of an opening chase scene. A bit of
a retcon reset after "Tokyo Drift," it begins in
the Dominican Republic, where Dominic Toretto is
still hiding out after the events of the first
film caused him to flee LA. With the help of his
girlfriend Letty and his pal Han, Dom hijacks a
couple of fuel tankers by racing alongside them
in his muscle car. It's a high-octane sequence
that shows off director Justin Lin's talent for
staging the kind of elaborate action set
pieces that became the series' trademark.
But things fall apart quickly when Dom returns
to Los Angeles to avenge Letty's supposed death.
Although it's fun to see Diesel reunite with
Paul Walker as former cop Brian O'Conner,
the duo's plot to take down a drug kingpin
inspires few fireworks. Admittedly,
the "Fast & Furious" series had yet to find
its footing by the time this film came along:
It wasn't until the next installment,
"Fast Five," that they ditched the formula
and shifted the focus towards a found
family of globe-trotting crime fighters.
You can see elements of the direction
the franchise would take in parts of
this movie — for better and for worse
— but nothing Lin and company come
up with can top the hair-raising
heist scene that kicks things off.
The overwhelming anticipation for a
sequel to "The Silence of the Lambs"
quickly dissipated the moment Thomas
Harris' novel "Hannibal" was released.
So shocking and lurid was the book's violence
that director Jonathan Demme, star Jodie Foster,
and screenwriter Ted Tally — all of whom won
Oscars for "Silence of the Lambs" — declined
to return for this follow-up. Only Hannibal
Lecter himself, fellow Oscar-winner Anthony
Hopkins, agreed to appear, with Ridley
Scott, Julianne Moore, David Mamet,
and Steven Zaillian taking up directing,
acting, and writing duties, respectively.
"Are you confused?"
This being a Ridley Scott movie, "Hannibal"
is nothing if not beautiful to look at,
even when the content makes you
want to look away. And indeed,
there are many moments when the sheer craft alone
may trick you into thinking you're watching a
masterpiece. From the opening sequence, when
the horribly disfigured Mason Verger — played
by an uncredited Gary Oldman — quizzes prison
guard Barney as to Hannibal's whereabouts,
Scott creates a feeling of dread and unease,
aided by John Mathieson's moody cinematography,
Hans Zimmer's eerie score, and Norris
Spencer's elaborate production design.
As the film progresses, however, you can't help
but sense some of the "Silence of the Lambs" magic
is missing. Part of the problem is Moore's casting
as Clarice Starling, the FBI agent tracking Lecter
down as he eats his way through Europe. As great
of an actress as she is, she can't erase our
memories of Foster's iconic performance. Yet
critics saved their harshest criticisms for
the movie's violence, which was still brutal
even with massive deviations from the book.
While leagues above the recent "Jurassic World"
series, "The Lost World: Jurassic Park" was
nevertheless seen as a major comedown from its
predecessor. It's easy to understand why Steven
Spielberg would want to make a sequel to his
monster 1993 hit, and individual sequences remind
us of his skills both as a visual storyteller
and as an action filmmaker. The film's opening
is particularly strong: A vacationing British
family decides to dock their yacht on the remote
island of Isla Sorna, not knowing it's home to
some of those genetically-engineered dinosaurs.
Their daughter wanders off and is greeted by
what appears to be a friendly Compsognathus,
but their interaction turns dangerous when an
entire flock of the tiny predators attacks her.
She survives, fortunately — but that doesn't
make the experience any less terrifying.
Once Dr. Ian Malcolm travels to the island
at the behest of Dr. John Hammond, however,
"The Lost World" proves that there's really no
good way to make a "Jurassic Park" sequel … even
though we got four more attempts at doing just
that. While the dinosaurs inspired awe and wonder
in the first film, here they're seen only as
monsters to run away from. Given Spielberg's
directorial talent, those chase sequences
are thrilling. Yet as critics pointed out,
the people doing the running away are little more
than dino food, aside from Pete Posthlethwaite's
entertaining turn as a big-game hunter who's come
to the island in search of exciting new prey.
"The trick is… to get him
to come where we want him."
Stop-motion director Henry Selick created
eye-popping worlds in his animated films "The
Nightmare Before Christmas" and "Coraline," and
the same is true of "Monkeybone." Unfortunately,
the characters he creates in this
live-action/animation hybrid aren't
nearly as compelling as their surroundings.
Part of the problem is Monkeybone himself:
As voiced by John Turturro, he's a cartoon
creation of animator Stu Miley — portrayed
by living legend Brendan Fraser — who finds
himself tormented by the claymation primate
when a car accident puts him in a coma. While
trapped in the bizarro realm of his imagination,
Stu links up with Monkeybone to
try and get back to his fiancee,
only to find out the little stinker plans to
use his body as a way to enter the human world.
Before Stu's accident, we're treated to a
glimpse of "Monkeybone" as an animated series,
which is set to make him a very rich man. Although
the raunchy cartoon is funny in short form,
we soon realize that a little bit of Monkeybone
goes a long way, especially when he inhabits
Fraser's body. Things liven up a little
when Stu, in an attempt to reclaim his life,
jumps into the body of a recently deceased organ
donor, played by the hilarious Chris Kattan,
who keeps spilling his parts all over town. If the
middle section were as good as the beginning and
the end, "Monkeybone" might've turned out to be
some kind of bonkers masterpiece. As it stands,
however, it's an ambitious curio, one that
appalled critics and scared away audiences.
Disney's association with "The Wizard of
Oz" goes all the way back to the 1930s,
when Walt wanted to turn the book into an
animated follow-up to "Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs." But the estate of L. Frank Baum
had already sold the rights to Samuel Goldwyn,
who in turn sold them to Louis B. Mayer, and the
rest is history. That didn't stop Disney Studios
from trying to make their own version of the
classic book series — including the surprisingly
dark "Return to Oz" — culminating in the
critically maligned "Oz the Great and Powerful."
"Stop! You're hurting him."
Directed by Sam Raimi, it stars James Franco as
Oscar Diggs, a traveling circus magician and con
man who's plucked out of Kansas by a tornado
and plopped down in the magical Land of Oz.
The locals think Oscar is a great wizard who's
come to save them, which he decides to use for
his financial gain. His magical abilities come
under scrutiny from three witches — Theodora,
Evanora, and Glinda — each of whom hopes to
employ him in their fight for control of Oz.
Copyright laws kept Raimi from using some
of the most iconic characters and imagery
from the 1939 "Wizard of Oz," including
Dorothy's ruby red slippers. The beginning
of his film — which follows Oscar's origins
in Kansas — is a callback to the original,
shot in black-and-white Academy ratio. It's
so good it makes you wish he had the rights
to make an official prequel rather than, well,
whatever the heck this movie turned out to be.
Tim Burton had firmly established himself as one
of Hollywood's most visually inventive filmmakers
by the time he took a crack at remaking "Planet
of the Apes." Unlike the most recent trilogy,
which employed motion capture CGI to
turn humans into apes, the director used
practical makeup effects courtesy of Rick
Baker. And this being a Tim Burton film,
you know the art direction is going to be
similarly dazzling. If the screenplay were
up to that same level of craft, there
might have really been something here.
Hope springs eternal when the film opens,
as astronaut Leo Davidson crash lands on a
mysterious planet where humans are enslaved and
apes reign supreme. There's a goofy charm to
Mark Wahlberg's performance as a spaceman
who goes into orbit to save his partner,
a chimpanzee named Pericles, only to find
himself captured by intellectually advanced
primates. The ape performances by Tim Roth,
Helena Bonham Carter, Michael Clarke Duncan,
and Paul Giamatti are fully committed
despite being hidden under pounds of
makeup. And not for nothing, but there
are also some impressive action sequences.
Yet as the film progresses,
you get the sinking feeling
that the three credited screenwriters
— William Broyles Jr., Lawrence Konner,
and Mark Rosenthal — didn't know exactly
what tone to strike. Worst of all,
the customary twist ending raises more
questions than it answers. The finished
product was a critical disaster that failed to
relaunch a franchise… and featured, well… this:
Roger Moore's final outing as James Bond in
"A View to a Kill" was a real low point for
the series, earning some of the franchise's
worst reviews. Yet even the worst 007 outing
still has a great opening sequence — albeit one
with a very noticeable stunt double for Moore,
who at 57 was starting to show
his age. Bond is dispatched to
Siberia to retrieve a microchip from a fallen
agent. When he's discovered by the bad guys,
he has to evade them by sledding down the icy
mountain, first on skis, then on a snowmobile,
and finally on a makeshift snowboard —
all while accompanied by the Beach Boys'
classic "California Girls." After blowing
up the helicopter that's been chasing him,
Bond enters a hidden submarine and gets cozy with
the beautiful submariner. And of course, there's
the opening credits sequence, set to Duran Duran's
theme song, aptly titled "A View to a Kill."
Bond later finds out the microchip is a product
of Zorin Industries, led by the villainous Max
Zorin — played by Christopher Walken doing
his best bad-guy act. Zorin has some nefarious
scheme to become the world's leading microchip
manufacturer by wiping out Silicon Valley,
aided by his henchwoman May Day. By this point in
Moore's run, the series had become so campy and
lightweight that it was difficult to take anything
seriously. Although die-hard fans will still stick
up for this film, it was clear that a massive
reset was necessary to keep the franchise alive.